i get it i get it the treehouse was only
used in the first installment but every
other piece of media has these things
listed as treehouse of horror specials
so until you get consistent with these
titles we will consistently
sin or something maybe there were still
elvis ain't dead jokes going on in 1993
but it'd been long enough that this
seems like a really lazy aside shame on
you simpsons
shame on you excuse me a balanced budget
is very much alive
it's the best feeling second only to
perfect proportions on peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches what's that
sex oh right yeah second only to sex
i have that so is this expressing the
idea that violence on tv was dead in
1993
pretty sure nypd blew homicide life on
the street walker texas ranger and
diagnosis murder would disagree
with you
the watching dead also i'm no zombie
expert but the simpsons breaking through
a perfectly constructed floor seems a
bit of a stretch
they have brittle zombie arms they would
crumble and break
everyone else got the quotations around
their silly halloween name but james
didn't so is his middle name hell for
real
or do people just hate the man paintings
lifeless images rendered in colorful
goop i was going to send bart serling's
opinion on art here but no
that seems pretty accurate so we'll just
send paintings yep
the sin is paintings now you hold maggie
i'm going to buy some earrings at the
gift shop
putting bart in charge of maggie well
there were a few left but we chucked him
at an old man for kicks
and did you also douse them in glue to
help them stick to the old man because
these would have slid off the back of
his head before he made it 10 feet
i was told recently that seders have
constantly erect penises
penai peace panera regardless i'm now
passing on this valuable information to
you so that we can all turn to our
neighbors and state you know flanders
really should have a visibly erect penis
here
you're welcome many people offer to sell
their souls without reflecting upon the
grave ramification
speaking of grave ramifications those
pectoral injections really didn't work
out for you devil flanders
you've got some serious bubbling going
on there hey wait
if i don't finish this last bite you
don't get my soul do you
if homer was smart enough to figure out
how to outsmart the devil then why
didn't he request more donuts
this jello is going to be flavored with
hot dog sandwich and chicken
and sure there's an entire box of baking
soda in the back of the fridge but do
your part and use containers to you know
contain the food freezer door has no
paper freezer door has paper
a year wide behind won't save you this
time if you have the ability to make an
opening to hell why do you not have the
ability to make it as wide as you need
it to be
wasn't he so the clock strikes midnight
and then the lawyer walks in but now the
clock reads 1 50 am
and when he turns to leave it's suddenly
12 35. i guess the old saying is true
time flies when you're having lazy
continuity errors yeah yeah pentagrams
are creepy looking and all but they are
actually supposed to protect you from
evolve so the devil is essentially
creating a barrier for himself
and wouldn't be able to enter the house
joe doesn't know how to pentagram
correctly
also if the show is bringing attention
to the possibility of summoning the
devil for a deal they should try to be
consistent with his appearance do you
draw a star thingy and light it on fire
or not
answer quickly this lighter fluid seems
to be evaporating more quickly than i
anticipated
the court of infernal affairs is now in
session
i'd like to point out that skeletons
have no lips or tongue so this really
should sound like
here you hear me
spelling donut with a ug it's just ugg
dad i wouldn't go outside if i were you
cops will do anything for a donut cliche
having a twilight zone parody in your
night gallery parody
if i lean over i leave myself open to
wedgies
wet willies or even the dreaded rear
admiral
maybe wedgies but wet willies are
actually easier to give when someone is
sitting down and facing forward
i mean don't ask me how i know really
kind of want you to like me
also screw you show now i have to add
rear admiral to my
incognito look up later list foolish
earthlings
kodos and kang have to make an
appearance in a simpson's halloween
special whether it makes sense or not
cliche
dad do you notice anything strange yeah
his hair do look so cool that's racist
hello mother
hello father burns vampy chompers are so
far apart
bart's neck should have one puncture
wound on each side
come join us lisa it's so cool
you get to stay up all night drinking
blood
simpsons lot also apparently vampire
powers give you an ability to speak
clearly through a window pane
not sure they even need to worry about
staking mr burns he's clearly going to
be set on fire at some point since he so
carelessly left those unattended candles
burning
i'm the head vampire this reveal is
frustrating considering march feigned
concerned for bart turning into a
vampire and also concerned for things
being too dangerous for maggie
and sure they didn't want us to suspect
marge but instead of saying
homer we gotta do something today he's
drinking people's blood
tomorrow he could be smoking she could
have said he's never been a bat before
he could hurt himself
the reveal would be in layers and we can
all have our shocking moment
happy halloween
uh okay i guess in order to relieve the
tension of seeing a
chopped up home or a decapitated
flanders in a vampiric marge
they thought they'd need to throw in the
most vanilla option they could find so
they gave us the peanuts christmas
special
[Music]
there's this proud moment in every
content creator's life when their
creative offspring head out on their own
channel adventures and don't need papa
cinema sins anymore well
that don't you forget we're all started
and get your ass back over to cinemasins
before dark
damn kids how is elvis and have you seen
him lately
of course i refer to
ew
[Music]
you're the devil i have so many names
[Music]
you will now answer to the charge of
being a grievously savage race